why is everybody talking about
semiconductor chips and why should you
know about it because your world
revolves around semiconductor chips you
want to know why you know the car you
drive how many semiconductor chips do
you think's in your car you know at the
low you know what that number is not 14
maybe you said 82 222 what if I told you
the least it's 1,400 chips all the way
up to 3,000 and the average chip could
be around Pennies on a dollar to 50
bucks and on top of that because of this
challenge you're with not enough of
these semiconductor chips being made car
manufacturers have changed their lead
time from taking 3 to 4 months to build
a car to 10 to 12 months to build a car
it it's such a big issue in that
automotive industry that they've said
from 2021 to 2023 they're taking 20
million cars off the conveyor build they
just can't hit the timeline and by the
way you know how long it takes to build
a chip anywhere between 10 to 12 weeks
all the way up to 20 weeks for the
complicated chips and in 2021 you want
to know how many chips we built
1.41 trillion chips so so look I don't
want to give you you know information
overload just on the intro all I want
you to know is this is something we have
to be aware of because our cars don't
run without any chips and a lot of
things don't and today it's become a
political issue between China Taiwan us
and many different places we're going to
talk about that today okay so if you
give Al add of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
okay so semiconductors right I mean you
got better things to be thinking about
but this is something we all need to
know a lot about and semiconductors it's
not about everybody so it's Taiwan no no
it's China's the leader but are they the
leader for selling it or buying it and
which chips are they the leaders in
because there's levels to this game of
level of difficulty you know you you
play game it's like I'm playing lowlevel
easy and then there's difficult like
soduko and then there's very difficult
and then there's like diabolical level
of difficulty it's the same thing with
chips so I'll break it down for you
where you'll see what products use these
chips and then what countries are
building the most who has an edge who's
a non-competitor and then by the end
will give you some feedback on uh what
this is going to impact the world
whether it's politically or economically
so let's first talk about what things we
use semiconductor chips in number one
Computing desktop computers laptop
servers tablets mainframes
supercomputers when it comes down to
communication smartphones landline
phones routers modem satellite
communication devices consumer
electronics we use it in televisions
radios camera audio players game
consoles smart home devices wearable
tech when it comes on to Transportation
Cars airplanes trains Marine vessels
electric bicycles and scooters Health
Care Medical Imaging equipment like MRI
CT x-ray Etc hearing Gates pacemaker
insulin pumps lab analysis equipment
when it comes on to Industrial in
automation Factory automation equipment
robotics process control systems when it
comes on to Military and defense
missiles missile Control Systems drones
radar sonar systems communication
equipment when it comes out to energy
solar panels wind turbines smart grids
when it comes on to financial ATMs point
of sale terminals when it comes on to
agriculture Precision framing equipment
drones for crop monitoring when it comes
on to retail barcode scanners Inventory
management system to most of us we
thought it's only cars right when you
look at this like all of these different
things I'm not even done yet when it
comes on to science and research
particle accelerators telescopes space
probes when it comes on to network and
data centers Network switches data
storage when it comes onto other
miscellaneous things watches digital
calculators GPS devices I'll stop there
I can continue but you get the idea
they're used everywhere there's a reason
why it's 1.1 141 trillion chips built in
2021 so look I've been in the financial
industry since 911 the day before 911
and I've owned stocks bonds mutual funds
real estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
years is gold I love having a percentage
of my network in Gold that I have access
to in case of many different things a
you facts you need to know about gold
number one the gold market cap is $1.8
trillion since 2000 the compound annual
growth rate for gold has been
9.24% and during times of high inflation
3% plus has been
15.35% now those are just some numbers
for you but there's some other benefits
to add gold to your portfolio number one
hedge against inflation number two
results showed recently that 93% of
central banks are working on AC cbdc so
this means what that could be a
manipulated currency that they own if
you own gold it's a non- duplicatable
asset your now hedging against cbdc
taking place number three a potential
cyber threat if it happens you don't
have access to your money you don't have
access to your accounts well you have
access to your hard physical gold number
four is anonymous no one knows you have
that gold and last but not least
diversification that's why we chose to
work with our new sponsor American
Hartford gold if you have retirement
funds that you cannot afford to lose
American Harford gold will ship physical
gold or silver directly to your door
also if you have retirement funds that
you can't afford to lose now is the time
to call American Harford gold a precious
metal dealer you can trust they have the
finest products amazing customer service
and a buyback commitment they've earned
a five-star rating from thousands of
reviews and an A+ from the Better
Business Bureau tell them I send you and
they'll send you up to $5,000 worth of
free silver on your first order so click
on a link in the description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 so I want to show you this chart
that BCG consulting firm did during coid
because everybody was worried about
semiconductors to show where America was
Leading The Way with semiconductor chips
in 1990 versus today if you look at this
chart with me the baby blue look at the
top left of the screen the 37% that used
to be Us's market share of building
semiconductors and watch what happened
every year every year it got lower and
China was at 0% but if you look at the
charts China started going higher and
higher because they realized they have
to compete in this area and this is
projecting that by 2030 China will be at
24% and we'll be at 10% but it doesn't
really tell the whole story so now when
the average person looks at this they
say oh my gosh this is terrible BCG you
got to respect them China's taking over
with chips what are we going to be doing
they have to explain there is levels of
difficulty to chips so did China commit
to building the easy chips or the
hardest chips we're going to learn that
today by the way Carly fiorina who was a
former CEO of hu Packard and she ran for
president said the following about China
although the Chinese are a gifted people
Innovation and Entrepreneurship are not
their strong suits their society as well
as their education system is to
homogenize and control to encourage
imagination and risk-taking because in a
communistic society you don't create
things you can steal other ways of
people are doing things but you don't
create it so Innovation it doesn't why
should I wake up in the morning and
innovate something there's no incentive
for it cuz that's not the system that
they have in China so what does all this
stuff have to do with America here's
what it has to do with America America
president Trump and Joe Biden if there's
one thing they're both on the same page
with where Biden pursued president
Trump's ideas is semiconductor chips let
me tell you the backstory of this in
2020 recommendation of President Trump's
National Security team representative
Mcall first introduced the chips for
America Act again in 2020 alongside
representative Doris Matsui a Democrat
from California Senators John Corin
republican from Texas and Mark Warner
another Democrat from Virginia this bill
was signed into law August of 2022 under
Joe Biden so started under Trump but got
into law under Joe Biden this has
nothing to do with democrat or
republican they both realize we have to
compete in this space so the whole idea
behind it is that it makes nearly a $53
billion investment in US semiconductor
manufacturing research and development
and Workforce the law also creates a 25%
tax credit for Capital investments in
semiconductor manufacturing okay so let
me give you the timeline what happens
from October 2022 till today first the
US imposed new export restrictions on
Advanced semiconductors and ship
manufacturing equipment to prevent
American Technology from advancing
China's military Powers okay export
we're not committed to that because
we're making them stronger two the rules
require us chip makers to obtain a
license from the Commerce Department to
export certain chips used in advance
artificial intelligence calculations and
supercomputing Technologies for modern
weapon system then restrictions were
designed to slow China's military
advance and prevent it from developing
Advanced Technologies that could be used
for military purposes the rules will
also allow the US to block foreign made
chips that are manufactured with us
technology this prohibits US citizens
from supporting China's Advanced chip
development the Commerce Department
defines us persons to include US
citizens permanent residents people who
live in the US and American companies
Dane shamaro Washington DC base head of
global risk and intelligence at business
consulting firm control risk said the
technology is nothing without the people
there to make it work for many senior
Executives at Chinese companies the rule
will likely force them to decide between
their jobs and their US citizenship or
permanent resident status obviously
you're kind of Corning them to make a
decision it's a power play here the
restrictions have had a significant
impact on China semiconductor industry
China is the world's largest consumer of
semiconductors but it produces only
about 15% of semiconductors it uses the
US restrictions have made it more
difficult and expensive for Chinese
companies to get semiconductors they
need the restrictions also slowed
China's development of Advanced
Technologies for example China is
developing its own AI industry but
advancing chips are critical for AI
development and the US restrictions
again have made it more difficult for
Chinese companies to get the chips they
need this is why the restrictions have
had a significant impact on China's
semiconductor industry and his
development of Advanced Technologies so
in other words four different things
this had an impact on China number one
slow China's military advances number
two slow China's development of Advanced
Technologies such as AI number three
increased the cost of semiconductors for
Chinese companies and number four
disrupted supply chain and CA
semiconductor prices to increase so now
that brings us to May of 2023 here's
what happens us Mexico and Canada
gathered in DC for the North American
Semiconductor conference called the nasc
then in June the Netherlands implements
export restrictions on Advanced
semiconductor equipment amid us pressure
to cut China off from Key chip making
tools the Netherlands which is the home
to one of the most important
semiconductor companies in the world
called asml Advanced semiconductor
materials lithography asml makes
Machinery that is required to produce
the most advanced chips remember earlier
we talked about there's levels to the
chips this is a part where Netherlands
has an edge because they know how to
produce some of the most advanced chips
in the world China doesn't have this so
while China is amongst the top
semiconductor producers it is not
capable of producing the most advanced
chips so this brings us to July 2023
where Japan alliance with us restricting
23 types of equipment machines that
deposit films on Silicon Wafers to
devices that etch out the microscopic
circuits of chips that could have
military uses and in August of 2023
President Biden banned us investment
into certain China Tech sectors that
develop or produce semiconductor
manufacturing AI machine learning and
Quantum Computing this ban prohibits
private equity and venture capital
investment flowing into sectors that
President Biden said help Beijing gain a
military Advantage the development of
more sophisticated weapon systems
breaking up cryptographic codes and
other applications that could provide
these countries with military advantages
the Biden Administration argues that
China is using us technology to develop
its military capabilities and to
undermine US National Security so this
is very important because for for for
the longest time you would hear these
big you know private Equity guys or
investment bankers or fun managers
talking about we're making investments
into China because China's the future
all these Economist would talk about
China and how much foreign money was
being invested into China so if you look
at this chart look what it shows us this
is China State administration of Foreign
Exchange so look at the black bar that
represents the net foreign direct
investment into China this is from 1998
pink is the outbound so outbound money
they sending out yellow is inbound money
they're receiving look what it's looking
like it goes all the way up peaks in
around 2013 and then all of a sudden if
you come to today look at the black bar
you'll notice it is the lowest it's been
since 1998 you know what this means
people are no longer investing in China
the way they used to because they don't
trust the government anymore this is
very very big news because it's not just
America against China it's the world
against China because they're learning
about their motives so now the reason
why that's important because if people
don't want to collaborate with them and
they don't make the expensive types of
chips where are they going to get it
from if no one wants to give it to you
because they're worried about you that's
a very problematic foreign policy
they're going to be struggling with here
very soon so let's take a look at what
chips they make a little complicated but
stay with me we're going to learn
through this together but you'll see
where China leads and lacks on this
chart so this chart here is from the
percent of Global Supply this is from
Bloomberg 2021 it's the market share of
global semiconductor Supply by Subs
sector and Country in 2020 so if you
look at the colors at the top you'll see
us in blue Taiwan is yellow Korea is
orange Japan is red China is burgundy
and Europe is green so now then you see
the charts see to the left where it says
Subs sector tech level this is the level
of difficulty okay so osat which is a
outsourced semiconductor assembly and
test it's a manufacturing vendor
provides third-party IC packaging and
test Services guess what lowest level of
test it's not that difficult anybody can
do it China spend their time building
what is the easiest thing to build so
what are fabulous chip makers these are
companies that produce semiconductors
for use in various Electronics digital
cameras smartphones new technology
sophisticated smart cars fabulous means
that the company designs and sells the
hardware and semiconductor chip but does
not manufacture the Silicon Wafers or
chips used in its product instead it
outsources the fabrication to a
manufacturing plant or Foundry examples
of companies that do this quacc Nvidia
AMD and others if you look there us is
leading the way more than 50% more than
60% then it's Taiwan then it's China and
nobody else but if you go to IDM notice
China's not on that list and IDM you
ready this is the difficult type of
chips to make that companies like Intel
Samsung and Texas Instruments produce
this is an integrated device
manufacturing IDM a Semiconductor
Company which designs manufactures and
sells circuit IC products look what
China is there nonexistent us pretty
much 50% Taiwan very small Korea comes
in here South Korea and then Europe
shows up with the green remember earlier
we talked about Netherlands this is
where you see the green Europe then we
go to Foundry Foundry model is a
microelectronics engineering and
manufacturing business model consisting
of a semiconductor fabrication plant so
for example foundaries are Global
foundaries
tsmc UMC these are the types of
companies that specialize in Foundry
model if you look at us this is the
least area that us doesn't remember the
level of difficulty for this is very
high then yellow is Taiwan this is where
Taiwan dominates in this section then
you have Korea then again China small
Europe non-existent and then when it
comes down to the materials you'll
notice materials here it's pretty much
evenly through uh in this area Japan
leads the way then you have us and it's
a bunch of different companies and then
for equipment us is leading the way then
you go to Japan then you go slightly
China then Europe here is doing what
they're doing so so if you look at this
listen we're all learning new words here
I'm not in the semi conductor business
I'm just realizing this is happening we
need to learn together here's what
you'll notice everybody here on this
list except for China they're all
allies remember enemy of an enemy is a
friend there's a lot of guys here that
are allies to us they're not even
enemies they're all allies but for China
none of these guys want to do business
with them they're pulling money out this
is catastrophic for China this is not
good for them so now let's talk about
sales to see where sales rank with us
and other countries when it comes down
to semiconductors if you look at this
chart from csis they did this study in
2022 this shows semiconductor sales by
country in billions in 2021 here's what
you'll notice Us number one in the blue
46% of it all is with us then it goes
second South Korea
21% then it goes to Japan 9% Taiwan 8%
and if you even put the rest of the
world at 9% last place here China 7% so
it's important to know and remember
remember during Co where we're like all
freaking out over chips oh my God we
need China for semiconductors and
everybody went to China then kind of we
realized China was using that as a way
to bully everybody it's kind of like not
a good feeling and if you treat
customers like that like they
desperately need you they're not going
to forget that when they no longer need
you look at this chart here okay this is
from Federal Reserve of Bank of Dallas
okay US Census Bureau shows the share of
total us trade if you look at the colors
blue is Canada green is Mexico red is
China obviously if you go back to '90s
China was last then it was Mexico green
then it's Canada at the top come all the
way down to 2020 when Co happens China
drops once us tariffs on China exports
announced during Trump if you remember
when Trump put those tariffs on exports
boom they took a hit it went all the way
down then Co happens the US is like oh
my God even with these tariffs we need
China look at what happens to Red with
China boom skyrockets but then even
after Co disappears we gradually move
away from China and we start going to
Mexico out of all the places Mexico yep
Mexico this was again not a good look
for China so so this next part is going
to get a little bit more complicated but
I'm going to simplify it if you want to
read all of it we'll put the link below
for you to study the research that they
did but here's what it is the value
chain the process of building a
semiconductor right so some may do one
part but not all the other parts and
they kind of work together so let me
break this down for you so to simplify
depiction of the semiconductor value
chain first you have Design This is
microprocessor design which underneath
it you'll see design software electronic
design Automation and then you see
intellectual property right license arm
architecture that's number one number
two you have fabrication this is process
Wafers that's when you need materials
and chemicals raw silicon Wafers and
neon and by the way a lot of neon you
know where most of neon produce in
Ukraine Believe It or Not Ukraine has a
lot of Neon right and Manufacturing
equipment lithography tools remember
earlier we talked about that company in
Netherlands lithography Netherlands
that's kind of when this is being
produced and a last but not least you
have assembly and test which is package
microprocessor unit so forget about
having to learn all the stuff what we
want to do is who are the biggest
sellers and buyers of all of this
whoever is the biggest seller has the
most control whoever is the biggest
buyer relies on everybody else guess if
you were to guess who's the biggest
buyer and who's the smallest seller wait
to see this chart let's take a look all
right so let's take a look at the total
semiconductor manufacturing equipment
sales and purchases 2021 in billions
look at the sellers color China is green
North America is blue blue Japan is baby
blue the rest of the world is purple
South Korea is yellow you see the
smallest color there green what is it
for sellers the smallest one is China
look how small they are in sellers but
look how big they are when it comes on
to buyers they need it but they don't
know how to sell it cuz they don't know
how to produce it the biggest seller is
US great then it's rest of the world and
Japan tied for second and obviously you
know second to the last is South Korea
then China's last biggest buyer China
then it's Taiwan then it's South Korea
then it's Japan rest of the world and
North America okay so now let's break it
down if we go to wafer fabrication
equipment sales and purchases here's
what you'll see again smallest seller
China look how small it is again they
they don't have leverage here then it's
South Korea then it's Japan then rest of
the world then us dominates in the area
of selling biggest buyer China then
South Korea then Taiwan then it's
everybody else then if we look at
assembly equipment sales and purchases
again different categories if you look
at the biggest seller here it's the rest
of the world look how small China is
zero pretty much then you got Japan as
the second largest and everybody else
and by the way us is not big here
they're small when you look at this but
they're a very small seller and they're
a very small buyer here and last one
remember the whole test equipment and
that whole process we looked at this the
third step testing equipment sales and
purchases biggest seller is Japan North
America second rest of the world South
Korea you can't even see China there
look at China can't even see them by the
way biggest purchasers here is Taiwan
then China so a few takeaways when we're
going through these numbers together
you're going to have your own thoughts
I'll give you mine China's in trouble
here so one I sit there and I realize
okay things are not as bad as the rest
of the world thought when it comes out
to this two China has to be friendly
China has to come and be nice to you cuz
they don't have leverage if you look at
the game of Leverage China does not have
it here the rest of the world does so
China has to be nicer but it's kind of
confusing when it comes down to China
because China just a couple weeks ago
said hey Apple no more iPhone government
employees can't use iPhone they're
banned from using iPhone to the point
where Tim Cook had to go meet with them
and say guys what are we doing we've
been partners for a while but China's
not dumb China saying yeah we're really
Partners really Partners yet you started
producing your phones in India and
you're making your phones over there hey
what happened with the phones you're
building in India I hear they're warming
up and they're getting too hot these
iPhone 15s so you remember this is our
Leverage Dame China's going to use that
so China's also not playing oh my God we
need help they're acting like they're
totally fine under control why maybe
because they're thinking what Russia did
with Ukraine maybe they can invade
Taiwan and if they take Taiwan over this
is not going to be a problem for them
they'll show up on the leader bulletin
like this if taiwan's under their regime
and this is one of their strategies but
it's not as easy as you think it is it's
very complicated for that to take place
a lot of people think it's going to be
just as easy as what Russia is trying to
do with Ukraine it's not it's more
complicated than I will'll do a video on
it but the best thing about this whole
thing is the world really learned a lot
about China during coid when we learn
what they do with power they bully
people and partners when you negotiate
with them I learned this a long time ago
you can negotiate hardcore with somebody
and win 9010 but they'll never do
business with you again or you can
negotiate with a partner and say listen
you got to make money I got to make
money but you'll do business with them
forever China showed during Co that
their style of negotiating is Bully
style of negotiating and the world says
we don't like your style so they're in a
rough place maybe they get rid of G do
not be surprised because they need to
bring a fresh face to say hey I'm about
diplomacy let's make this work let's
build some relationships that's
sometimes what companies do when the C
was liter too powerful and strong they
got to bring a new one to say it's a
fresh phase let's make this work so
anyways we don't know if any of this
stuff will be Tak place but all I know
is when you look at these numbers it
doesn't favor China by the way if you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
there's another video we did on China
called the China's economic apocalyptic
situation Daren if you've never seen it
click over here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye